الينا من شرق اوكرانيا المتحدث باسم
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه في الجبهه
الشرقيه
اهلا بك معنا بالنظر لما يجري في القرود
وهذا التعليق القادم من مستشار رئاسه
الاوكرانيه بان المعارك هناك تشكل نهايه
عصر الاستقرار بوتين ما الذي نفهمه من هذا
التصريح
اعتقد انه كان يعني
ان منذ بدايه هذه العمليه العسكريه كان
هناك اخطاء كبيره من الجانب بوتين كان
يعتقد ان المجتمع الاوكراني والقوات
الاوكرانيه الضعيفه ونحن
نقوم بتدمير قوات العدو هناك حوالي
200,000 من قوات العدو قتلت على اراضينا
وقوات فاجنر قضينا على اعداد كبيره منها
ونحن نستمر
بالمواجهات ونرى الان في بلغراد كيف يقوم
الاحرار ضد نظام بوتين اعتقد ان هذا ما
سيقوم به
القفقاديين ايضا وسوف تسقط الامبراطوريه
الروسيه في اقرب وقت الجانب الروسي يتهمكم
بانكم تقفون خلف هذه العمليات في بلغرود
ما تعليقك
هذا لا يتطابق مع الواقع ولا باي حال من
الاحوال نحن ندافع عن اراضينا في ضوء
القوانين المعترف بها الدوليا والحدود
المعترف بها دول ولكننا راضين عن
المجموعات التي تقوم بهجمات ضد نظام بوتين
النادي ولكن هذه حربهم هم هل لديكم تقييم
لحجم هذه المجموعات وكيف يمكن
بالمحصله ان تخدم اهدافكم اذا كنت تقول
بانكم راضون عن ادائها
نحن راضيين عنهم ولكن هذا ليس الجانب الذي
انا مسؤول عنه كمتحدث باسم القوات
العسكريه لكن ما يجري في القرود كيف يكون
تاثيره على نهجكم الاستراتيجي في ظل
حديثكم عن الهجوم المضاد اذا
[موسيقى]
ما بدا في بلغراد هذا طبعا يشتت القوات
الروسيه
وجبهاتها ونحن نضربهم هنا في اراضينا
ونقضي على الكثيرين منهم في الليله
الماضيه في بخموت قتلنا حوالي 39 جندي
وحوالي 60 مدرعه دمرت
ومدفعيات ايضا
كل هذا
مجتمعا يدعم العمليات العكسيه المنتظره
ويحضر التربه لهذه الهجمات القريبه وتحرير
جميع الاراضي من الاحتلال الروسي الحديث
عن الهجوم المضاد هل له ارضيه يمكن البناء
عليها في ظل ان هذه المناطق باتت في يد
الجانب الروسي وله
مؤيدين في تلك المناطق بعد
اعلان الاستفتاء عليها فهل لديكم ارضيه
يمكن البناء عليها في الهجوم المضاد
الحديث حتى تتحدثون انتم عن شبه جزيره
القرم اليس في ذلك مبالغه او طموح كبير
للهجوم المضاد
ان افضل
قاعده لنا هي القوات العسكريه الاوكرانيه
التي شكلت بفضل الدعم من الشركاء وقوات
الدفاع كما تحدث عن الوزير ريزني كفو
وجنود الذين يتدربون في اوكرانيا والغرب
وهدفنا هو استنزاف العدو باكبر حجم ممكن
وتدمير معداته وجنوده حتى نقلل فرصه في
الدفاع عند بدء العمليات واعتقد ان في وقت
قريب سوف نحرر الاراضي الاوكرانيه وسوف
ترون هذا جيدا
المتحدث باسم القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه
من شرق اوكرانيا شكرا جزيلا لك